readings from podcast Ville the church
what's happening now is brought to you
by addict listen to me I fly like a
[ __ ] animal and I use eyelid [ __ ]
supplements in and out of airports
what's the one I screwed tech I'm the
immune room tech sport [ __ ]
tremendous as far as alpha brain who
else gives you [ __ ] 100% money-back
guarantee and they don't want the
product back nobody has that [ __ ] that's
why I love on it that's why I [ __ ]
working on it that's why I've been with
them for the last seven years
so do me a favor you want to get some
great supplements whether it's the
Mexican chocolate protein powder the way
or gap everything they got is solid go
to Alec Connor and check out press in
church BAM and get yourself ten percent
off delivered right to your [ __ ]
house who's better than on it nobody
number two I love this product right
here this is my new favorite friend on
the road solo Jitsu knock Tom you like
Joey what the [ __ ] is so legit dude
cough it's a deck of cards he just flip
it over and it tells you to do practice
sprawls and you practice frogs then this
one here is standing up the door pulled
it's just standing you know and then
this one here you bend it over and you
got [ __ ] bridge grunt bridges this is
it this is a tremendous little [ __ ]
thing you just a little product you're
in your hotel room you do dip escapes
and you can do whatever that tells you
it's a solo game you play by yourself
you smoke a bowl whatever you're into
gonna solo jet2.com and take a look
you're gonna be [ __ ] surprised kick
that [ __ ] mio Lee Kansas City's own
[ __ ] Chris Porter in the house what
up what's up beautiful whats up thanks
for having me man off always a [ __ ]
pleasure I just read the body every
[ __ ] weekend on Twitter you destroy
another room and it's so weird how
people just think you just showed up
like I love this about Tommy Leigh like
people like where you've been
when I been I started Connie when you
were in grade school you [ __ ] yeah you
know there's only where that's why I've
been [ __ ] yeah man it's so crazy
how people just think you just popped up
dude I was I didn't the Comedy Store the
other night and Rogan looked at somebody
goes as he knew and I was like [ __ ] dude
I've been here for like 10 years man
but yo you changed yeah I'll have that
kid look t no more you know Jew fro for
a while yeah
yeah yeah got it so now you're
respectable
yeah yeah I look like an adult you trim
the beard absolutely yeah I got a girl
that does it for me now sure yeah yeah
it's nice a lot in listen it's really
weird when you build this town for a
while and you see comics and we've all
aged we've got kids we got into this
[ __ ] game yeah maybe kids kids only
gotten for this [ __ ]
and all of a sudden now you see comics
they have families I know break
Fitzsimmons oh he was single you know
[ __ ] like that like my Jobrani before
kids are Brian Cowen Joe Rogan for great
things
ya know and those are the dudes have
made and then there's a bunch of dudes
back home back home I've never made it
out here because they had the kids too
soon it's crazy I got a buddy I talked
to him he came out no before me and
chillon he's like I think I'm about done
I got two girls and it's like I don't
know what to tell you man well you know
it's it's rough for people to know the
types of comics that are out there yeah
there's national touring headlines like
Chris Porter and Joe Rogan people like
that bill burr then there's guys that
are just regional that maybe they have a
job as a school teacher maybe like them
one of the best comics I've ever seen
working as a guard Chicago I forget what
his name is and he's on a radio show in
Chicago yeah but he never left because
he had four kids and his and his wife
and him were school teachers or
something absolutely and you know I told
somebody about him was like a dog I
opened for this guy in Myrtle Beach and
he destroyed the room when the guy goes
to see my fire filleted I think it was
Jimmy Schubert who told me the story
yeah she miss you but those bro let me
tell you a story about that [ __ ] dude
has a joke about a bus driver about that
oh yeah we got some and he's a white
dude but he does like a black bus driver
he breaks down every candy they have for
the day this is 20 years ago yeah we got
you you bees we got em remember you have
it was a joke that went something like
that but it was just a brilliantly
written joke like you sit there as a
comment in a while I'm really watching
like the cop I was doing common like
eight years nine years
Sky's a [ __ ] pro and when you saw
those you know we were in comedy doing
89 years when you saw those guys you're
like wow I'm gonna be that good
absolutely it's really we that this guy
I was telling Schubert about who should
we go to brown years earlier when
Kennison was alive the rule was when
Kennison played your town he was coming
for the Late Show at the combat view
that comedy club so if he did a theater
in Kansas City yeah he would see improv
for the second show yeah and the owner
would tell you listen there people
called on Friday Saturday we're gonna
pay so let me give you the light get the
[ __ ] off absolutely what pod stage we're
gonna pay you just don't worry about it
like what's your pal would show up to
the punch line back in the day yeah well
yeah don't let you ego bother you yeah
here's your money this is your money
just go home
have fun you'll enjoy a week off so so
supposedly they told this kid Kennison
in town in Kennison came in he saw
Kennison and started speeding through
the material and Kennison goes no don't
give him the way this kids killing me
yeah kick got on stage and chance didn't
even follow though because I said I said
I'm done yeah I'm done you have to come
on the road with me the kids like I
can't yeah kids I'm a teacher you know
[ __ ] like that
absolutely this story's just like that
Doug there's a guy what my favorite
comic workings Chad Daniels and I and
he's getting his Jew for the most part I
think well I think that guy would be
humongous but he lives in the middle of
[ __ ] Minnesota oh yes a drive two
hours into the airport I think but you
know he's just a good family man
anything he wants to be around his kids
and [ __ ] but probably the funniest dude
working right I would I don't knock
those guys yeah because they knew
exactly what they wanted the very
beginning when I started in Denver there
was two or three different types of
comics the comics that wanted to be
stars Steve McGrew there were common
said just a Tribble runs and kept it
local and has a day job played it safe
maybe had a girlfriend and then they
were comics who we're reckless you know
don't want is that you look at and you
know that don't comedy just as an excuse
to drink and party yeah
that's it and we get [ __ ] you see it
you smell them a mile away you know it
that's well I think the really good
comics run through all three of those
phases
oh yeah yeah no yeah you you really have
to find that's why it takes twenty years
that's when it takes 18 years yeah
that's why it takes 16 years dude I love
it what a comic that's been doing it for
years goes I found my voice oh I left my
okay
I know exactly what point you're at yeah
absolutely just by talking to a comic
now from doing it for so long
yeah like I know what you're like I know
that you kept then listen you have no
[ __ ] idea yeah you found no idea and
you don't want to put yourself in the
position where because he'll be
traumatizing yeah it's like going to
Vietnam at 16 the scene 22 dead [ __ ]
people but shooting sounds bad that's
out traumatising it is when you get
somewhere where you don't need to be or
something like that there's a pattern
and there's a system is a formula and
that formula has worked for 2,000
[ __ ] years and guess what I've seen
that formula work and I've seen
everybody have a different formula I
remember people go on to me how many I
remember this kid from acting class once
came to the store saw me and they're
like this is 198 yeah 99 I've been doing
comedy maybe nine years and he saw me
like the next acting class he's like I
could do what you could do and I
remember even then looking out and going
like at that time I just came off that
bombing in Buffalo yeah like I had this
life-changing Bobby okay like we all
have these bar absolutely along the way
that you remember like you have a bomb
at the fourth year that's traumatizing
there was a bombing I took and a as a
buffalo sat a bar and it was a buffalo
savory game at halftime that was the dip
that was the King okay you did halftime
of a buffalo saving ham they just I
didn't know it was just a place with a
tree it was like gladiator oh yes it was
like BRR in Philadelphia yeah it was
like burn so no bird knew what he was
going into it any attacked them yeah it
seemed like four people were already
Guinea I didn't know what to do I got
attacked
yo dude so is it like burn Philadelphia
doesn't seem like a bomb to me
no he almost like he went reverse that
was what made a brilliant okay he didn't
let himself bomb he went up dead knowing
nothing he could do yeah that's very
strong when you look at an audience and
go you know there's nothing to do with
these savages it's like when you get
yourself involved in those midnight show
oh I open up your mouth I'll do a
midnight show and their [ __ ] puke is
coming out of their eyeballs you know
passing out yeah and you're bombing
going wide myself involved with a
midnight [ __ ] show
yeah wait those number year 20 years ago
the midnight show just come out it was
always late started a quarter of what
yeah you're lucky you're dead you're
dead
yeah you're dead devastatingly the
hosted go 20 that's he's hammered yeah
he you're dead those late they had to do
away with them The Improv did away with
them because the comics even said it by
this by the second show some nice you
don't know after especially on a Tuesday
when you go to work on a Tuesday work
that's my Saturday you don't know what's
coming out of your mouth you don't even
know where you're at three shows on his
animate the second show were you like
that I say this already
dude I opened for Tracy Morgan like 13
years ago at the West Palm improv and he
was doing our 30 and they'd still have
me do 30 in front of it and so I think
the midnight show actually started at
1:45 so I went on it to those shirts
didn't even get over till 4:00 like it
was in Santa's and say have you said a
joke multiple times of the same said
ever although tell you oh no you see it
on their face immediately the the
curtain has been lifted no that's what
I'm saying so you've done a you get four
words and you can just feel it's like so
you said abortion like you just it
[ __ ] it sucked out of the room it's
terrible you have no idea that the
journey I sipped like the main question
I want to ask every comic in this room
that comes in here from now on so young
Thomas no listening is at the four year
mark did you have that epiphany I tell
well as comments we haven't had the
first five years every six months you
ask yourself
but my donor my [ __ ] that in here
this is this because I think four years
in I was kind of on the road by you're
already feature I was starting to I had
already featured yeah first time my for
yeah yeah for years that I was already
featured well I get what listen when you
start in Kansas City it's not hard if
you're a little bit funny and kind of
cute and you can carry 25 minutes you're
gonna get a lot of work and I think
that's what I learned very early is that
and no offense to the people that
struggle but for me being funny was kind
of easy it was like it was trying to
have a point of view all funny yeah
everybody who gets on a stage it has to
have a slight angle of confidence that
they said it did something that they
thought was funny at one time yeah like
I didn't start realizing it what people
would tell me but I didn't really start
realizing it like about a month or two
before I got arrested
yeah was a low and maybe I'm onto
something maybe these guys are right but
now come on me
I do blow I [ __ ] but then Tim Allen got
arrested for coke
Richard Pryor lit himself on fire so
these are all promising things for a guy
those are all promising [ __ ] thing
yeah
and then I got locked up in the prison
library had ladies and gentlemen Lenny
Bruce okay
telling Brent this did you two guy the
other day ago after the comma stones to
his house to watch the fights and I was
telling him I go you know you
I read that money Bruce book and I was
like wait a second so this guy works in
a strip club and goes in between
strippers right there that's just pretty
much fun then he goes home to the
Chelsea Hotel a hotel that's fun right
they're living in the hotel that's a
[ __ ] blast and he hangs out with jazz
musicians and other strippers would come
back to the hotel they lived there too
and they shoot heroin and they sleep all
[ __ ] day then got up at 7 or 8 he
done it and go do comedy at night I mean
I thought was like I could pretty much
handle that yeah that's what I'm
build Pam's Syria but that that's sad
yes that that's the that's all I thought
I could do with 28 on my I could do that
I could shoot a little heroin but did
you had you done heroin and did you
realize how this oh that time I had
snorted heroin maybe once yeah twice but
that's a way different thing than
putting it in here right no I wasn't
going to shoot I don't know I don't like
needles yes I was just want to do a
couple bumps at night yeah what I I just
want to be part of something that wasn't
part of something you wanted to be a
pirate like I wanted to be yeah like I
want to be a boy scout who i joint yeah
with this too many [ __ ] rules yes and
then when I was a kid you know and maybe
I could be an associate of the mob
family so many [ __ ] rules you know it
was just everything I wanted to do had
always too many [ __ ] rules this was
the only thing that really had no rules
but there's no rules you just show up
you say what you want to say you do what
you want to do yeah and there's no rules
on either side you know and then they
come to you one day when you don't count
me four years and go hey man if you keep
doing that type of material you'll never
be in a letter middle one oh I'm right
there you have to decide yeah you know
what [ __ ] it I rather be myself
yeah a [ __ ] did not be oh that's big
decisions when you're a comedy thing you
have to make it the fourth or fifth year
or go you know what I could work a clean
set alternate there's a lot of great
guys like you that could do a clean
[ __ ] and said I can't do it clean so
if you paid me so what like what are you
guys because there's a few different
levels of when you say dirty like
they're swearing and all that but
something I've noticed since I've
started is people who are like I don't
know if you call it shocked or whatever
you want to call it where it's like
they're just saying things that don't
even nothing you've you wrote them down
be funny with it now they're trying to
get a groaner
well you don't have a point of view okay
so your point of view is to go up there
and shock be there's no point of view
now some audiences will laugh at the I
can't believe he just said that okay you
know what I'm saying
very few of them but like stone frat
boys will laugh at that [ __ ] and you
don't know how many
times I've seen dudes go up on stage and
do something and you go oh I know what
happened you said this [ __ ] when you
were high around your stoner ass friends
last night and it killed so you
remembered what you could and now we're
on stage we're hearing it and we're not
high and we're not your friends and none
of this shit's really [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] crazy that's see I've done that
a thousand thought we all have
absolutely
we all have that's crazy you just find
yourself going oh mate there's there's
stuff that I didn't say and that's it's
wild because I mean as a comedian I'm
trying to I like to make people laugh
I'm I don't know cuz Joey said something
to me a couple weeks ago that I've
really been not struggling with the
thinking about he said that I should try
to work clean at least a little bit at
the beginning I don't see myself as
dirty but there's a couple of jokes that
I do that talk about sex and I don't
it's kind of because there are no rules
it's kind of hard to know does that
count as dirty can I not talk about sex
at all it's iggins I'm trying to figure
out what's allowed my advice to young
comics is to write clean because you're
you're gonna say [ __ ] cuz it's your
natural person so if you write [ __ ] and
then you get nervous and you say more
[ __ ] that's double [ __ ] so and then
that gets to many [ __ ] so like I say
write clean remember the bits clean so
it can talk about sex at all or no 30
I'm talking about like hold on say you
could talk about whatever the [ __ ] you
talk about as long as you know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about you have
conviction would you would be the
woman's [ __ ] now then then don't talk
about sex because you have no right to
you won't need a woman's answer so you
have no idea about sex this is why I
told you don't talk about sex you've
never come you dated a girl for four
years we refuse to come in the mouth you
bought into the fact that she didn't
like morning sex
wait so you can't talk about sex because
you're not a sexual person why are you
talking about those things on stage
that's the funniest things you never
came out it's [ __ ] ridiculous weird
and even though the accident oh nothing
odds are it's ridiculous so he's not a
sexual dude it's like me going going on
a stage and talking about computer nerd
[ __ ] yeah
browning about that [ __ ] I don't even
know the URL is no do I want to know
yeah you got it
so you should be talking about how
you're not a sexual person I I guess I
don't want it I'm not gonna do jokes but
I think it's more like mic because I'm I
had years of girls who even before my ex
I had multiple exes who just were into
it but not really into what [ __ ]
well I had one girl saying don't go down
on me because I'm not going down on you
that was the worst I didn't see end of
that really you attract that he attracts
that because he doesn't shut the rules
in the beginning yeah that you learn
along the way yeah but back to the
comedy for me with him anybody else like
when I started I didn't write Chris I
didn't write the first year I didn't
write I will up there and I thought I
could just I thought it was just showing
up yeah and I bombed all the time and
then I got a job as a house emcee and I
started writing but I realized something
that was the same people every week so
every week I had to write a new fireman
it's what an education that was yeah and
every week I'd die the smoke that once
in the [ __ ] law I still remember
using props got a vogue yeah they had
the cones on their tips oh absolutely
I came out with cone doing that like I
tried everything you're talking to a man
that used to walk up on stage to a rap
song I'd say hey everybody you ready
have a good time they go yeah I go you
already have a really good time say hell
yeah they go hell yeah I go alright
let's get naked and I tell you all my
shirt and I was super skinny and of
course no one took off their clothes so
we get weird and then I'd go okay well
okay it's kind of bailed on that so
here's my impression of a greyhound and
then I would get up on the stool and I
would suck in and all my ribs would show
and I would look like your granddad like
that was my opener so like I totally get
[ __ ] a strong open with weird [ __ ] and
a music is you're just finding your way
yeah it's years it's years you know and
I love
this guy going to me like I am Lindo you
do and then a [ __ ] week later I saw
him he said he got showcase from
Montreal yeah he was doing a set at the
black Club on [ __ ] that's still
there but nobody talks about the comedy
Union yeah oh it's on Pico Pico
yeah only talks about it no more nobody
well no data but none of the white
people you happened uh nobody even black
people I don't I'm sorry Jackie favors
about it the other night
really she goes down and she goes down
there yeah like it's the weirdest thing
like I was down I don't know what the
[ __ ] were talking about being down there
well we're openers finally your voice it
just uh it takes so long and then oh he
got a union that's what it was that kid
went down into the open mic I guess
somebody from Montreal gave my showcase
its third time on Saint and he called me
up on the sound my Twitter on my pager
and I go what somebody goes bro how long
you been doin count me for you I don't 9
years II was I've been doing comedy
three times and I'm already going to
Montreal yeah [ __ ] sabotages before
even know that this is me you don't know
you know this is the beginning yeah he
died a bag of death never went to
Montreal then he opened up a restaurant
up here yeah he took his family savings
his wife's and he opened up a restaurant
and they would do comedy in the back
patio and he was the house MC and he was
trying to get people but he wanted clean
town he didn't believe in dirty like
that 28 he didn't like dirty economy and
he opened that up and that died the slow
death he's back in New York
[ __ ] there's a way to five years ago
this week manager at the Friday's I love
when people come up to me and they're
doing comedy five years and tell me what
they're doing and I'm like I know what
you're doing I been here
you can't even open up your [ __ ] mouth
teeth doing comedy eight or nine years
you don't even you don't even say a
[ __ ] word I was doing the top I did
Tommy Chong comedy at 4:20
time and it was like the worst
experience ever just because we showed
up it was 118 degrees in San Bernardino
where we shot it our hotel room the
[ __ ] air-conditioned was broken so
it's like 85 degrees in our hotel and I
brought this girl with me who'd been
doing comedy for a little bit right
before I went onstage Tommy by the way
had pneumonia
like we're at pre-production he's on a
cot shivering oh my god like not making
words and we're like we're all looking
at each other we're not gonna do this
right and they're like no wait you know
we know there's like a hundred grand in
this production we have to do it so and
also this audience it's like the third
thing they've saw at Jay Mohr did a
special Ian bagg de special and then we
were the third thing is the Montoya
special yeah yeah this is Scott Montoya
so first comment goes out just fine
second comment goes out his his mic cuts
out for 8 minutes Shelby goes out and I
don't know if you've ever seen Shelby
Chong do comedy but it's it's it's rough
and it's site that a daughter or what's
his life that's his wife
it's it's tough so then Tommy goes out
and he's about 18 minutes into a set and
walks off stage mid-sentence doesn't say
work he has to go throw up the director
comes out he could have said a lot of
things Oh
Tommy's [ __ ] up man Tommy had too many
cookies he's got to just chill out for a
second no he didn't say that what he
said was Tommy Chong is deathly ill and
he's going to the hospital so I didn't
start standing up getting ready to leave
guess who's next
by the way me and so they after like
corral the audience back I go out
onstage the first eight minutes of my
set is unusable they're just staring at
me and you know how tapings the
audiences are lit so you're just you're
looking at these people look at you and
so you're just finally I got I did 20
minutes like the last seven minutes was
TV passable get offstage
I get back to the group to my dressing
room and this girl's like so I have some
notes I go are you [ __ ] kidding me
she said I thought you might want notes
from a peer and I looked at her I said
there better be a [ __ ] eye in that
word you better be talking about a place
where we parked boats because you have
been doing [ __ ] for [ __ ] five years
there's we're not Pierce you're just a
girl that's done comedy for a little bit
and also I know I just ate a bag of
dicks I don't need to [ __ ] go over it
with a fine-tooth comb it's no no no I
know exactly you know you've been doing
it for so long
yeah you know exactly well I know you
know it's when I did this Netflix thing
I knew when I got off stage where I went
wrong
yeah how I prepared for it the wrong way
like you just but this is part of the
[ __ ] journey yeah and you look in the
mirror you man up you take that notebook
guys you get the feather you get some
chicken blood and you start right yeah
and then you get on [ __ ] stage and
that's it yeah and you there comes a
point where you fall in love with it
like this morning I call them four spots
at the store at 9:01 there was nobody
there
yeah we call it 10:30 when they're
supposed to be there but that means that
you're back yeah I went back to my open
mic that is no more when they said if
you want to be on open mic ever called
Tuesdays at 3:00 yeah you made sure you
call that 250 [ __ ] nine I remember
going to open mic in Kansas City and the
show started at 8:30 we'd be there at
5:00 hanging out we grab dinner and we
just sit there and write for [ __ ]
what you start at start at Stanford and
Sons in Westport
so the year was this 98 so the open mic
was on Sundays oh my you can't our open
mind was Monday's so I'd go to work go
to college come in and then I'd come
straight to the open mic and we'd be
there you know especially initially when
Emory Emory ran
to open my there'd be like a we'd be
there an hour and a half beforehand like
people would go up rehearse their sets
and they'd get notes and like people
would try to tag it it was a very
communal atmosphere and but it and but
at the very least you got to go up there
and run [ __ ] before you actually did the
show
alright so Stanford his sons had how
many clubs at that time just the walk
okay so when I got into comedy in 91 in
92 I dated a girl who was from Lawrence
Kansas go Hawks and I drove home without
a watch he drove Ottawa
I drove home with her to Lawrence okay
she was large but then she went to jail
and we went to watch them play and then
we drove on a Sunday night for me to do
an open mike at Stanford and sons and
the guy had the guy that ran the room
then wasn't Emory Emory it was somebody
else if you say isn't that but this is
1992 yeah you were a kid I absolutely
was I went up there I thought I was hot
[ __ ] they gave me six minutes it was
just brutal and I Mumbai bomb in front
of her her mother like her [ __ ] step
but the family out to watch it you have
no choice people to invite themselves
yeah
all you're doing comedy to invite
themselves you know the mother didn't
like me the stepfather had a wig
everybody had a [ __ ] wig on a family
uh-huh stepfather he real father both
had wigs yeah how crazy is what's
grandpa's pulling it off yeah like I
guess she was a waitress at the Commish
Club she was a waitress at the bar where
I did family on Tuesdays so she kind of
knew where I was in my comedy career I
was just you know it was just a Tuesday
and I mean they paid me 50 bucks and fed
me
and I sold pills there I sold valium so
I was making people come up there they
would pay to come see me they were all
you never draw no I make him [ __ ]
come up it was just such a scam I was
doing yeah but that year was sight like
I would just do Tuesdays I wouldn't do
the comedy works
yeah just do the boulder broker on
Tuesdays and then sadly I would drive to
like [ __ ] an hour to get on this
place that was huge and I just go Bob
she was like a bowling alley in Denver
hello Emily Clark that was my repertoire
yeah cuz I started getting guest sets at
McKelvey's and I would just Bom Bom Bom
man what a [ __ ] it was horrible
hey I had nothing else going on so it
was like who cares I just keep bombing
I've heard a lot of negative things
about starting comedy in LA but the one
thing I'm very grateful for is how many
open mics I have I have tons of open
mics like I've been very spoiled so I've
been 101 mainly and last night I went
with another buddy of ours Eric who's
just on the podcast we tried three that
I'd never done before that was it the
way that the bar for like two hours it
was it wasn't as easy as just going to
the fourth wall but it was fun I enjoyed
having the one show a week when
especially starting cuz it like gave you
spent all week looking forward to that
one like that was your show a show that
was my I wouldn't sleep on Monday nights
oh yeah or Sunday nights no I would I
would do my tattoo of my Tuesday night
oh yeah
Tuesday night I would stay up on Monday
night and right my friend was a baker
and he would take Tuesday's off so he
would stay up on my Monday and bacon I
would taste all the ice creams and
gelatin and all the [ __ ] parfaits he
made and I stay there with him drinking
coffee or I might write jokes yeah and I
would not sleep it was it was you just
looked like that was your night to like
oh it was like your club you go there
all your friends were there by that
especially if you'd been doing open mic
for more than a year like most of your
friends were those people so it was like
it was equivalent to like going to like
a recreational softball game you know
you're just like your team's there you
guys ready to do it you're hoping to win
have a good night and you know some
nights you didn't sometimes you did how
long did it take Stanford and son took
now one of the clubs went close to you
at that time was just Santa and so it's
just Stanford's and it was just Westport
and then but the cooling
like you could go to Omaha two and a
half hours and do an open mic or st.
Louis and so and that's what what's cool
about like wait you couldn't send anyone
links you'd have to like make a VHS or
and that [ __ ] was expensive so we would
like four of us would drive up to Omaha
and do an open mic and then one of us
would try to stay sober enough to drive
back and I honestly don't know how some
of us made at home without DUIs or just
long trails into a cornfield especially
driving back from Omaha we're just
hammered drunk the memories that I
there's memories in my life like I had
you know a baseball game or like Joe
Namath football camp but those first 10
years economy they're [ __ ] edged in
my mind
priceless forever and there was a lot of
hard times like [ __ ] out a window in
Seattle in the office like this I would
just get up in the middle of night and
go to the hallways [ __ ] out the window
and you know because it was an office
with no bathroom yeah just like I can't
even describe it like that that journey
is so [ __ ] unique and you have to do
it you have to do that journey that
whole I don't know what's gonna happen
tomorrow journey yeah like you have no
idea like this is it this is it like we
got three weeks worth of gigs we got $16
and this is it
I remember being Wisconsin doing these
one-nighters for what was her name up
there that booked at the comedy cafe she
booked Marquette University I don't know
that she gave it to her daughter this
was a dude I think this dude's name was
Hanson or something
Tom Hanson yeah yes okay so I show up to
this gig and like 99 times out of 100 if
you want to advance you just show up and
like hey can I just after you do the
show you're like hey kind of get some
cash a little work I just did well this
was like a bar where they like had
contracted the work out I was
new to this whole concept and they're
like now we don't I'm like I have $18
and 200 miles to it like I don't have
enough money for food and gas so if I
don't have any cash and dude had to wire
me money like I remember just going back
to the hotel where I'm calling the guy
that booked their thing for me like I
need something or like I'm literally
stuck in but whatever the [ __ ] Wisconsin
I am right now eight you know because
I've literally I thought I was gonna get
paid after this night now all those guys
I took to the premiere The Longest Yard
at one time or another borrowed $2 from
each of them I told them all I need 200
hours at one time or another and they
all told me the same thing this is not a
loan this is a gift this is an
investment in your future yeah don't ask
again I would buy a gram of coke don't
say it's so at least fifty dollars worth
of coke and I'd used the other money and
those are the guys that would send me
the hundreds and they would say I put
200 in there don't ask again yeah
absolutely I put 200 in there don't even
I will I don't even wanna back back but
don't call back here again looking for
money like I had people who really
that's what you do don't you do when you
get into calmly you you have a support
group around here people you know and
again if you trust the universe these
people will come to you and some nights
they got 10 bucks and some nights you
got 10 bucks
soon I remember right after that we'd
film The Last Comic Standing but it
hadn't come out yet
so you know you get all your TV money
when it airs I was [ __ ] I got to this
College thing and they were again
thinking they were gonna pay me a lot of
money and they they're like oh no we
sent it to your man we sent to your
agent you'll get it in like two weeks
and I had a
our $100 from Christian Finnegan might
be right Hey
I can just straight up like hey man I
thought we were getting paid or not if
you give me a hundred bucks I'll make
sure you get it back and then either
like call the agency and be like tell
you hundred dollars from my check put it
on his check kiss he gave it to me and I
and still whenever I see Christian
Finnegan I buy him a beer for that [ __ ]
because I you know that was just another
time where you know especially o-5 like
you weren't cell phones weren't huge at
that point the internet definitely
wasn't so you're just [ __ ] especially
when we started cell phone I don't have
a cell phone when I started definitely
have GPS I remember buying an atlas
every year I had to have a cell phone to
2004 I was the last good another block
and sprint gave me a 200 a month credit
because of my bad credit yeah if I was
two hundred and one dollars they shut me
down you know how many mornings I got my
phone was shut off when they go down and
they say you're a dollar 34 and like
that you gotta be [ __ ] [ __ ] me
huh so I would just pay $40 every time
you know I just built it up and then one
day this and you have no credit but it
was crazy but I borrowed money
constantly like I big that's how I
became friends with Ari Shaffir
I needed a plane ticket and I looked
through my godö I need toilet horse I'll
get the tea in two days I gave it Tony
knows I thought I'd never see it again
yeah people were pissed at me for giving
it to you right now I did that [ __ ] fee
is now I need all the friends I get and
it's just wait like that's what you do
you just it just happens every month you
just barely make it for a few years but
that that's part of toughness that you
need for this [ __ ] I'm going through
that toughness you develop their efforts
get you through the 10th 11th 12th 13th
year when you come out here and now
you're going on auditions yeah and now
you're dealing with that all that stuff
all contributes to that that's what
people never see they try to skip
I can't skip it it's like peds or you
can either pay me now or you can pay me
later but you're gonna pay me now you're
gonna pay me this money I don't give a
[ __ ] way do you think what they told you
or what you expected but you have to do
this to become this because if not
there's gonna be so many [ __ ] holes
in your game I was doing comedy I was a
regular at the store and I've been doing
comedy nine years and I had a little bit
of a hack you know saying like I'm gonna
be able Montreal and I'm gonna have a
deal but I'm following Paul Mooney every
night [ __ ] and in my world that means
a lot more than what the [ __ ] you do and
I had a little bit of an ego and they
had to be probably February of 99 but I
was starting a headline that was hard to
headline all right
Harvick never put me in my position yeah
you do like five minutes of fire yeah 15
minutes of [ __ ] hard hard wire
yeah you know you're just stringing a
bridge basically horrible like just
[ __ ] it's uh and you think like
you're really [ __ ] good and I got a
spot on freaky Monday did you ever get
to do freaking run this I don't know
what that a freaking Monday was at The
Improv from about 97 till about two
thousand three or four before it went
the urban night it was it was the urban
night but they were very slow in those
days yeah from eight to 840 it was white
so it would be you from eight to eight
ten Josh wolf from 8-11 to 821 me and
then they would put a super hot white
guy
the hablo Doug Stanhope yeah and then
they would bring the black axe they
would you know and then it would be my
9:30 was all black that's it you could
see the white leave the room ha ha ha it
was [ __ ] with that because the
industry was up there like in those days
if you got on stage I'm freaking Monday
Fat Tuesday Latino night at the Laugh
Factory you got an agent you got a gig
you got approached people would talk to
you there wasn't that much computer
people would have to come out and see
you yeah it wasn't that there wasn't
that much streaming yet so when you
would do those rooms people come out and
one Monday I moved myself up you know I
started freaking Monday at the for first
they had a six minute spot and if you
did okay for the six minute spot then
they give you like an eighth yeah
and they give you like intense and every
week they messed it up and it was pretty
weird like that you got a triple crown
that used to be the old Monday thing if
you do Latino night freaking Monday
neither the spot economy stores is the
open mic that was a triple crown one
o'clock is born you walk into the
college like what [ __ ] I'm doing the
triple crown tonight [ __ ] so I
don't forget following I went down there
and they said somebody cancelled and
they go we have a spot for you and I had
a follow Stanhope and bring up the power
and I thought it was pretty [ __ ] good
like I thought at that time honesty
honestly guys at the eight nine month
Magne amor I had a pretty killer 30 yeah
I can rap six [ __ ] minutes good high
energy [ __ ] oh my god Stanhope took
it to another level I went up there they
the bag of dicks and then Nick DiPaolo
up there and a nerf and destroyed the
room which made my confidence feel you
know and I didn't belong there
that's it I was in the spot where I saw
myself going yes while the people would
have said that a lot of people would go
that's nothing the sound wasn't right or
they're black they don't like me or
whatever
love like something didn't work out
there that's not supposed to be and I
think the next week I was all around
like that's it that's it that's not
gonna ever ever happen again I'm gonna
make sure that this never ever happens
again and I went on a two-year Greyhound
fly and track whatever I would leave
with six weeks and put together 28
really yeah don't ask me how I would
leave with our Paso Miami improv Myrtle
Beach the one Club John X would give me
the DC improv okay John X would give me
like one night the DC improv I would
just go up top eastern border
Philadelphia nothing New Jersey would
give me a one night at Rascals and East
Orange or the other one there was a room
in Syracuse wise guys steve Schirripa
brutal Ripper he liked me and he would
give me two weeks Toronto had a room
that was run by a magician that didn't
pay was six hundred a week American to
headline two weeks but Mitch Hedberg did
it yes I said when they offered its head
break that I did it was Brewer you
staying over the club I was two weeks
and one week you're in downtown Toronto
and the other week you were in the
suburbs the guy that ran the club was a
whole-school Russian Jew Boris yeah and
Boris his brother so Boris would run the
downtown club and that was cool
there was a bar underneath they would
called Toronto would like Toronto would
coming yeah yeah yeah that was right
downtown was 600 a week there was like
this Tuesday through Saturday and
[ __ ] this the following week they
would put you in the suburbs and his
summer room and that sucked and his
brother was a driver for a hooker
service like you can't write this [ __ ]
Yeah right you can't write this [ __ ] so
soon as you got there the first nipper
brother would say first of all you
shared a room with the brother oh I hate
that so you were in this room with this
chubby guy that smell like salami that
could not get laid and what he did was
drive hookers around on Friday and
Saturday from midnight to 8:00 in the
morning so you wake up late in the
morning and he'd be sitting on the bed
eating like a sub five feet from me it
was brutal
ah guys this is brutal dude I remember
Stanford's back in the day was a [ __ ]
he than just a 10 of heathen reviewed
Balkan I could get xanax
I could literally just give my coat to
the bartender with 60 bucks in one
pocket and when I left that night there
being a the weed in there in the 60
bucks to be gone and then you could just
get and there are strippers over here
that were definitely hooking on the side
and it was just you just show up and
like the world was an oyster but just
nothing was good when you go home now
what club do you play
I do the amp well Stanford's is closed
but they banned me
oh so this is officially closed well
done
yeah the wig is done the wig is done
well no one left check Jeff died Jack
died a few years ago
Craig's I guess thick stand the dad
might outlive all three son so Craig is
the one with the wig Craig's along with
the way okay so I never I did the open
like bond I never even dreamed to call
him again I went home and I looked at my
guy there comedy clubs and I just
slipped a text through that one I'm not
ever calling them again so I get a call
one there from Roger Paul yeah and he
goes hey they want to hire you at
Stanford they go are you [ __ ] kidding
me no you going to Kansas City I go okay
I'll go [ __ ] money yeah of course but
the first time I went I'm lying to you
it wasn't to roger paul it was true bill
birnes management at the time agency
this is when I got the longest yard
okay they hired me okay and I was
horrible when I got the radio the guy
said put your jokes on a piece of paper
I'm like what are you talking about
remember Stanford's head Arena oh yeah
yeah yeah the guy was a blond head guy
or something Oh Johnny Dare he's still
there really this until better the worst
to do oh my god then they wrote they
bought like a robot they they went into
my business together and that that
dissolve to rock and roll it was called
Johnny dares oh my god yeah good that I
still remember that [ __ ] and then like
that that kind of you know Craig's not
somebody want to go into business with
and Johnny Dare found that out
so alright so the first time I go Lane
Craig picks me up I don't know who the
manager is he shut the radio he will
argue in the hallway to the [ __ ]
thing yeah it was five of the roughest
days of my life
I didn't know what I was doing and I'm
kind of behave myself well just so
people I just want to throw it out there
so people know when you do that radio
show he just says how you do when and
that's basically your cue to do like
five minutes of material they want you
to do your material they want in it's
just like but without laughter so what
about flying yeah and it's just like man
can't we just can we just hold your news
stories and like I'll make funny
comments and like I'll be funny and not
have to burn 25 minutes material but
they don't want that they just cuz you
can't do that material that night then
right no it's stupid
but yeah I do a little what happened
though so the first time I went I didn't
have any credits and he treated me like
[ __ ] but the second time I was I had a
bunch of credits so he was like he was
we gave me extra money and Popeil had
booked law and order SVU so I couldn't
do Tuesday night or something no I
couldn't do Wednesday so I I flew in
that night so I land in Kansas City and
whatever the [ __ ] you lando Kansas I
don't know you like you know way up
north of Missouri Missouri side I land
there and I get the luggage it's 10
o'clock at night there's nobody hit the
[ __ ] luggage and often I see the cop
lights I think I'm gonna do with me you
know I got a little weed in my pocket
but ain't nobody saying and they say you
know a guy comes on he gives you Joey
Diaz at me he goes I'm your driver the
manager from Stanford he's [ __ ] up
yeah his jaw is [ __ ] gun he's just
character he's coked up and he's like
she's come home you know what do you
have your license which and when my gang
goes tell them that you driving cause
it's Rob he went to open up a club in
Toledo hi I'm Ron oh my god he has a
chick in the car and they [ __ ] up his
[ __ ] I get in the car I got a make
believe on that I once did so much
cocaine he got fat like he went he got
he got skinny
he got coke skinny and then he did so
much cocaine he went the other side and
it bloated him now where is he though I
don't know I heard
good not good thanks no he was a mess
that night he was join the chicks join
strongly the column like how you guys
doing now I'm a coke crane yeah I'm
getting off a plant I haven't done coke
and two nights I'm like how you guys
doing
Yeah right you look like just the people
I've been looking for what I'm laying
well you got any more of that [ __ ] in
there way wait you're talking about yeah
I don't make any more of that [ __ ] and
they were you talking about and I
stopped the car I go I will get that
[ __ ] cop right now here right [ __ ]
now yeah where can we get the grandma
[ __ ] coke tonight after you put me oh
we're just messing with you
we got an honest we'll wait out for you
they gave me a grandma coke you told me
not to tell the staff then the next time
he told me not to give him one of the
waitresses coke that she goes crazy well
that's the first waitress I gave oh yeah
yeah yeah she was a beautiful young girl
usually she followed me around all night
because she had a kid she was hot
and she couldn't afford the coke and she
came back for the hotel room we did a
thousand dirty things it was horrible it
was [ __ ] horrible
let me blast away oh yeah like he told
me don't give him a coke I don't forget
she was dry humping the chair one night
it was just crazy it was just a week of
what he's saying the hills
it was just mockery there was maybe two
or three drug clubs and in the circuit
that would drug-infested that was one of
them that I went three times and all
three times I got [ __ ] up every [ __ ]
just nods I remember there was a dude
that had a limo service and he ran the
limos for for Stanford's but he you know
he had other businesses but he was like
man if you just give my driver 40 bucks
so I'm coming at you at the airport so I
flew in from New York I just happen to
get stopped by the DEA this is before
9/11 but these guys come up to me I
guess also my parents had upgraded me as
a birthday present so I'm a [ __ ] 20
year old kid that's showing up in first
class maybe I was 21 because I was
hammered and I so the three DEA agents
stopping pull out their badge so like
yeah we want to go through your luggage
and I'm just drunk enough also I have a
pipe I have a weed pipe I'm probably
half a bar xanax and not and I dust of
weed probably
and but I'm still freaking out I'm a kid
from Kansas I'm at an airport and I'm
like nah man like you can't just stop me
again this is pretty now you can't just
stop me so yeah I'm just walking down
the street you can't just stop me and
even like well we can search your bag
cause you're in an airport and finally I
just gave them the bag and just searched
they had a dog come in and search it and
he didn't hit it they let me go I take
the limo I go in you know you're 21 I
have a limo on your home and I go
straight to the club the limo driver had
already called the club and been like
Porter got stopped by the DEA everybody
assumes I got weed on me so they think
main thing I'm going to jail I walked in
they people thought they saw a ghost
they're like what the [ __ ] are you doing
here I was like I just I got away they
they embossed me and they're like oh
well welcome let me buy your beers is
that all there is to doing cuz I mean so
when you guys first started touring you
guys both seem to like to party a little
bit was there a time when you wouldn't
do anything because I don't want to make
the wrong impression or just like
[ __ ] your feet you go I can remember
one time me and my buddy Brett Clausen
God rest his soul
we would go to the Cleveland improv we
would have our two drinks and come back
to the condo where it was stocked with
liquor and beer and we would just get
shit-faced but I the old Cleveland the
old Cleveland and brother flats the yeah
on the other side the condo was across
the street from a bar yeah the Anchor
Bar Matassa
the last time I was there was not a good
week either
the last time I was there was the first
season of The Sopranos and I went down
on Wednesday night and I did coke every
[ __ ] night so Sunday morning till I
left I even got on the plane wacked like
yeah the last two lights I didn't sleep
at all
sad the strip club across the street
filthy strip club where they gave you
lunch I never went to that prom not a
strip club
you know me neither but they wouldn't
you got to that within those days this
is 98 yeah the first time I went to the
Cleveland Improv was 98 siren nine that
was bangin yeah she used the book and
she had an assistant and she was
powerful she was very powerful in the
improv chain she booked Buffalo Miami
Cleveland and she was kind of a witch of
a woman you definitely didn't want to
make her mouth you didn't want to make a
man that she got mad for any [ __ ]
reason I don't one time I booked the
commercial I had of cancel buffalos he
goes what else do you have with me I go
Cleveland Miami she was taken off the
books
yeah next time don't book a commercial I
almost [ __ ] cried yeah she was a
[ __ ] real [ __ ] and then she had a
book me in Miami and then she quit yeah
she quit she some people just can't
handle get to stressful game yeah you
know she used to date how they got to
calm me was her Alex Reymundo and Ron
White they're all knew each other with a
lot of white was on the podcast we spoke
about her she used to date Alex Reymundo
oh really that's how she got to the
Cleveland improv she was like a waitress
in Texas and then something just [ __ ]
crazy like some crazy story and she
became one the most powerful chicks at
the imposition quit in the middle Dave
Becky was a [ __ ] bouncer at the in
Tempe yeah yeah could you imagine being
some headliner there was a dick to Jay
Becky and now you're just [ __ ] in
Hollywood hell you're never getting out
because you said some [ __ ] to some
bouncer it's 30 years ago there was so
many people who abused like you know I
laugh at the Harvey Weinstein's there
was so many [ __ ] people who abuse
their power as Comedy
Booker's when you were young yeah this
such dicks to you but then again I was
blessed with some great guys that I'll
never ever like I was talking about Andy
Payton there was this other guy who I
camera more his name was what's the
political comic oh my god old bill Bauer
ha Bilbao that's a deep pool well he had
his name was Bill Bauer also but he was
a motorcycle mechanic he worked on a
motorcycle place he really Colorado he
booked 20 rooms you know how many times
I call that guy for rent in advance and
we go like bill like I can't pay August
rent yeah it's the [ __ ] sixth you can
give me four miles and book me and he
would go drive up I'll give it to you
and I got dates for you he would give me
the dates to work it off dude I had the
exact opposite cuz I came up and then
Craig Glazer camp I remember that dude
pulling dates I'd have a date book for
months and then the week before would be
the last week of the month it'd be the
26th to the 28th and he'd pull that [ __ ]
around one time he pulled that [ __ ] cuz
the headline I didn't want to follow me
he was a local headliner a guy that got
a TV show for six weeks moved out here
spent all his money moved back never did
[ __ ] ever again what's today
his name's now named Steve and Steve
[ __ ] didn't want to follow me so he
went and complained to Craig Craig
called me and he literally said I don't
want to hear Steve [ __ ] all weekend so
my cancer I was like bro last week a
month this is my this is literally my
rent check that you're taking away from
me and he's like take it up with Steve
so I had to call Steve and luckily I've
been on the road enough to where I knew
enough Booker's to where I had an I had
some leverage and I was like yo dude
I've never really asked any Booker to do
anything for me so I have some I'm just
saying if you pull this week for me I
will call every Booker I know and just
tell them you're a garbage
person and no matter how funny you might
be you probably not the kind of person
you want to get booked and and that is
the only reason I got to pay rent that
month was because that [ __ ] was
like okay you could work for me just
because I I had to threaten basically
his work when that but but that was all
Craig Craig just didn't want to deal
with it you remember a couple of years
ago Madonna about ten years ago Madonna
had a [ __ ] auction for charity
of all the people turned it down huh
rejection letters rejection letters it's
not already my allowed and people will
run to the [ __ ] hills like she just
embarrassed like thirty [ __ ] people
or he you today yeah then had the
opportunity to sign Madonna it's so
weird how you just did something I
wouldn't do either I just asked you I
just didn't know if you like the guy
that but I know ten [ __ ] today
that ones complain at a club well they
know they had to follow me dog and I had
like four people and I'd forgiven them
over the years because I get it but oh
my god there was one guy that even the
club all them one night seven down they
said look here's the deal it's Thursday
you don't want to improvise you don't
want to talk to the audience you don't
want them to work dirty you got Madeline
for work saying that joke what can he do
why did you take the [ __ ] shot all
was great yeah this club older like went
off on the headline who later on when
I'm last comic standing out a little
revitalization with his career but he's
a [ __ ] bum as for I was like
concerned because he just couldn't
follow me had two different clubs at the
firt the first week he didn't [ __ ] yeah
at the second we had a little leverage
at so he bitched and it didn't it did to
no avail
the audience was digging me and I knew I
know I know a guy that pulled a [ __ ]
gig from me one time that's still
working and will I see him now though he
looks the other way and I would never
hold it against it I get it but it's not
something I would do now if I can't
follow the feature I just say it yeah
I'll just say it listen I can't follow a
feature but while I ego I
and it's [ __ ] horrible when they go
crazy like they're like huh
I don't wanna and I get it I get it I
get it
in some situations I'll give you a
showcasing for HBO at the store I don't
want the guy in front of meeting all of
them be [ __ ] Johnny creative with
sparklers [ __ ] yeah because you always
hear how well they went to see they went
to see Chris Tucker for American history
accent ooh they've given it to Joe Torre
it's the guy - hi Tori and then they
went to see somebody else for the Bruce
Willis movie and they fell in love with
Chris Tucker yeah that fifth dimension
something about all these stories they
take all the stunts look at Lee for a
Bruce Willis movie all sudden they hi
Chris talk to you like what the [ __ ] I
used to yell at your manager why would
you put a black guy up in front of me
that's [ __ ] funny why would you do
something like that oh yeah there's the
shot of my life do it before I got any
kind of TV credits and you're you were
there where you're like you should be
headlining me no other credit right and
you're not gonna be blind so you do like
you'll do like the headline Wednesday
and then you're open for like John
Witherspoon Thursday Friday Saturday
because no matter how well you did all
he had to do is go up there and do his
five lines from Friday which I've never
seen anyone handle that [ __ ] better than
John Witherspoon he goes up onstage does
every line from every movie you wanna
[ __ ] hear no context he just rattles
them off like here the [ __ ] they are and
then he just goes right into 55 minutes
of really good comedy that has nothing
to do with that [ __ ] and so but like
once he does that [ __ ] it doesn't matter
what the [ __ ] you're doing so like when
I was in that level like that's what I'm
saying it's just like you have to get to
that level you know that level is a
shitty level - it's a shame level so now
you're funny
yeah so now you've done everything
you've done everything you funny you're
[ __ ] great you know how to write
you've been doing comedy for 11 years
you're ripping rooms a [ __ ] part oh
yeah [ __ ] ripping [ __ ]
part but but Wednesday shows up and
there's 35 [ __ ] birds not even that's
when you learned that it's a business
it's a business and you have and people
have to know who the [ __ ] you are then a
guy comes in there puts a wiggler and
those impersonations
and there's a line around the corner
yeah and you're like oh yeah what am I
doing wrong I had to follow a dude at
The Improv the other night that could do
he could beat box while singing [ __ ]
bass lines and then he can sing like a
[ __ ] bird and then he would crush he
would sing every hot song that you've
ever known from and he was that guy that
was like oh you like this song and he
would sing like the newest hottest song
and they'd be like here's my song and he
was seeing like the older song and it
was I found myself like in the back just
like yeah get it it's fun I'm like who's
the dumb [ __ ] got to follow
this dude oh [ __ ] it's me and it's like
how what the [ __ ] am I supposed to do
and literally the only way I could
follow him was to go on stage and go why
the [ __ ] do I have to follow them like I
thought we were just using words and
this this dude's coming up and doing all
this [ __ ] just crazy comics who will go
up there mix comedy with music and
destroy a room do what it's done well
it's all really a really its
effectiveness [ __ ] there used to be a
black guy in this town called James
Stevens the third you're my name is from
Seattle Washington me and Joshua had the
pleasure all playing from and he was
like a big-time or up in Seattle he's
that comic that came down and made it so
I came back he rented like a [ __ ]
Porsche at the airport they took us to
strip clubs every norm and he was on the
Stephanie Miller show at the time it was
on ABC it was after a politically
correct like if you stay up till 1:00 in
the morning but people would he was
still selling tickets like he was a
local favorite but he was a regular at
the store and he would level the store
but the black guys did not like them the
other black guys just [ __ ] hated him
but here's the thing about that stuff
it's like when it were
it's amazing when it doesn't work it's
an hour of the most excruciating [ __ ]
you've ever done like it's not like
there are a few of those guys that can
put the guitar down and do stand-up I'd
say maybe three or four but for the most
of the guitar [ __ ] ain't working or the
musical shouldn't work done they're done
tie done but not only that they got no
way to it like if you and I get up there
and say we're yelling too much or we're
talking too fast or something we can we
can readjust in the middle of a set
because we're being real or true to
ourselves I would say not the guitar
acts aren't but that's definitely a
character and but you and I are able to
be like all right you guys need to you
guys are tired of me yelling at you so
I'm gonna chill the [ __ ] out and maybe
we're just gonna talk in this moniker
and that meanwhile guitar act it's like
what are you supposed to do it's like
this [ __ ] ain't working maybe do some
more Van Morrison or something like what
what do you do at that point I have seen
[ __ ] like that one James Stevens a third
I saw him blow up the laurels and
problem was that I just standing
ovations huge and then one night like I
became friends oh and he would come to
the store and do spots he like Paul
Mooney and everybody else and one that
he went up devil level the [ __ ] room
I got my Thursday night there was like
80 people that and then he Griffin had a
follow let's keep it going and Eddie
Griffin his name was James Steve is the
third but any girlfriend and the rest of
the black guys cuz he was black
everything Jane let's keep it going
James Stevens a turd did you right
through his [ __ ] face they would say
it and Hedy Griffin was ruthless at that
yeah yeah ruthless and he will update
he's like let's keep it going for James
Steve was the third I don't think that
[ __ ] saw the Sun on the [ __ ]
store it's the comedy store not the
goddamn music hahaha
never forget that me sitting back they
going oh
Eddie Griffin is not [ __ ] around
let's keep it going for James team of
the turn I guess nobody told this
[ __ ] that this wasn't the [ __ ]
music store
this was the [ __ ] comedy store
it's so funny to see comics react to it
cuz to me like it doesn't bother me that
much but I used to follow it and you're
on the road and you're [ __ ] dying all
week and you see this guy that is
singing Springsteen songs from the
eighties you ever see he's hunched oh
yeah of course really brilliant
brilliant he thought you'd go on stage
with four people attached to his back
bro what Dyke puppet top oh now I
actually like people and he be a
preacher hey bro it sounded like he won
a [ __ ] chorus he was brilliant try
following that I gotta follow him one
down the original room I found a
magician last night oh yeah that's a
slope that - if magicians just put just
piss people off it just makes me laugh
ten minutes a magic is the most people
could tolerate after ten minutes people
like ah okay
they stop getting fun yeah and then you
gotta follow what was the Kozak oh you
wanna hear a story about hit me with
Kozak I got a great Kozak's
know what year this is probably Oh ten
okay but what the [ __ ] alright so did
you you heard that right
yeah there's an actor the [ __ ] other
little Cucaracha be made that's roughly
maybe pick up a pie epic but I'm also
[ __ ] from like night I grew up in the
80s where that was just some dudes car
right hey they just reached under the
dash at I was a horn but so I'm doing
the Trop in Atlantic City and me and
this feature actually remembers last
name anyway
Kozak's doing every night 6 p.m. show
Sunday we go see him it's us a large
Jewish family I'm talking full-on black
black pants white shirt yarmulkes all of
them there's AG another couple and then
there's us it's a light crowd he's doing
Joe it's like a family friend
sure he's doing jokes about ex-wives and
boners and [ __ ] and so I leave like it's
a fun show but it's like there are
definitely times where like bro there
are [ __ ] kids in the room and so I
tweet just saw Kozak the completely
inappropriate family-friendly magician I
get a I fly home I get a call from the
owner of the trap who I hadn't met I
talked to for like two seconds on the
radio or on the telephone
fly home take a nap wake up to a phone
call from him like yo Kozak's mad at you
and I caught so you have to call it so I
called Kozak and I'm like what's up and
he was like yo I heard about your tweet
I think you're gonna damage my
attendance I got 2,000 followers at the
time right I go let's break down the
numbers here Kozak I got 2,000 followers
at best 10% of them are in the Northeast
New Jersey I go high-end I got a hundred
followers in the New Jersey area of
those people how many are in Atlantic
City
maybe twelve so maybe four people didn't
come to you if they're my followers
they're probably gonna come to your show
because I tweeted that [ __ ] and he's
like you don't know the power that you
have I was like I have no power bro I
got 2,000 followers and I just had it
was a it is just arguing with like a
prisoner like was he drinking at the
time I don't [ __ ] know no cuz he was
being like I worked on New Year's at
$2,000 yeah to Cain when the world was
an end and I'll pass oh yeah he was the
headlining and I had just heard all
these stories about him he came down and
it was just [ __ ] nuts I hear that a
part of his contract was he has his own
bottle of booze every night no she's
like a certain your own bottle like his
certain booze that was his okay yeah
like a sack Oh clam oil something like
that yeah he would just drink Crown
Royal came with a sack and so it was
Tuesday through Sunday and New Year's
being a Saturday night and Sunday or
Friday night something like that and
she had a no-show New Year's Day he did
a comedy show for kids okay
but this is when he was getting [ __ ]
up he was getting [ __ ] ham at those
days he was drinking a bottle that [ __ ]
every night doing blow
yeah smoking cigarettes I'm doing blow -
you know I'm not doing it with him I go
back to the condom leave New Year's Eve
and I'll pass that he was just [ __ ]
crazy
I met a waitress next you know what
having sex in the back and next thing
you know she's out getting drunk and
another comic is going mother my back
swapping spit with her and I just came
in the mouth and their mother the ATM
machine I mean this is just crazy
it was just [ __ ] the crane that I had
left with another girl it was [ __ ]
crazy New Year's Eve and I wake up
New Year's morning and the show starts
at like 1:00 if they're gonna have a
little show two o'clock it's 9:00 in the
morning
Kozak already has his [ __ ] magician
shirt on ironed boxer shorts the old man
socks rolled up to his knees dishing me
suspenders on and he's just sitting
there with half a gallon of that gallo
wine
oh [ __ ] like that [ __ ] drink yeah well
it's like five bucks for a handle but I
reckon that [ __ ] it's 9:00 in the
morning he's watching college football I
think and I'm like dog it's a bit early
for this he's got a couple lines on the
table so he goes I'm gonna do the kid
show you know me dog I know I'll
entertain this I follow oh you want on
the show no no that's a kid show well
same as a magician yeah and I walk in
and I could see Bart look at him this
like Jesus Christ you reek of alcohol
you know like he just still a kid show
and he's wreaking out of all the kids
who walk through these at the bar
drinking shots his [ __ ] finally goes on
stage and he's [ __ ] up and finally
some kid looks at me was ill you smell I
mean just I mean you know and I'm in the
back Howard cuz oh yeah [ __ ] and at that
time the head of the MC was a little
Mexican dude and the reason why Bart
hired him was he cleaned the movie
theater and he cleaned the comedy club
so Bart so Bart made me don't think I
wanted to be a cop
we would torment them that the word on
the street was never you game your intro
it was like six pages like write a time
he would go on stage and like this next
comic what the Catholic school so Kansas
City Missouri hysterical yeah
so we [ __ ] he was the janitor at night
so I'm for the comedy club with clothes
like well night long he would say hey
pick that straw up you know because he
have to [ __ ] like from the stage you
yell at people I picked yeah cuz he that
is what we're trying and I don't have to
come back that night and do it so one
night he begged this he goes just my
years of experience boy you're not gonna
throw graffiti around so that I mean the
confetti yeah oh yeah picking up one
piece of time that's all I needed to
hear I went out and bought confetti just
I was having a joke yes I did oh and I
had when they said happy new yesterday
only come Freddie everywhere next day he
went there at 2:00 in the morning the
next day at 5:00 in the afternoon his
wife was stalling ahead to these she's
picking them up good Freddie just quit
oh yeah he comes onstage and he goes
right to the bar and people are taking
pictures with you then they just wanted
to talk to you yeah and he went right to
the bar I started drinking and then
people come over and kids who do do a
magic trick and he was smoking a
cigarette and he'd had like a [ __ ]
shot glass in his hand that important
how to say something like they talk
about kids but the [ __ ] cigarette
away I mean there's more to the story
yeah but I know I forgot it was [ __ ]
hilarious he did something with the
pigeon disappeared oh yeah the pigeon
wouldn't fly out of a hat like [ __ ]
something just crazy
let me guess for shoutouts that's crazy
Robert Siriano happy birthday Ben
McClure
Brady McConaughey Ryan Watts - Jeff quad
Rex Meg my girl the Omaha [ __ ] charts
burial Sullivan and the true nji
whatever the [ __ ]
don't forget this Thursday I'll be at
the Kansas City improv and then at the
end of the month
I'll be at Nashville and an Alabama will
get that [ __ ] later but this Thursday
Friday sadly it's hysterical Friday
night I got 100 tickets all cuz Rogan
than down and now the Rogan is really
gonna song cuz they gonna boycott a show
the Christian Baptist whatever Baptist
Church yeah Western oh yeah that's going
down there so now I'm really doomed
nobody's coming to my show say some [ __ ]
about the Westboro Valley Church they
come down and ban me and call me a
healer that's a lot of people where they
could send a couple people down to your
show what da [ __ ] yous couple rooks
couple of new guys sent him down to the
Joey Diaz show so you shooting a special
yeah shootin independently for a great
company I spy in fact he called me today
[ __ ] nuts
Brian yeah I'll be dying
I gotta shake him down he doesn't know I
know this [ __ ] FBI dude that's the
FBI on that took down the bonanno's okay
for $5,000 going through your business
and find out is he robbing from me and
if he catches you he'll report you say
yeah yeah that's a civic duty so you're
[ __ ] up oh I just don't want to pull
him up Brian's ass cuz I'll be a [ __ ]
don't help me give me a mark man
although hypee in the comedy world yeah
I got that guy was Brian's ass but it's
uh it's a civic duty one numbers special
is history
well I guess technically three cuz I did
one I did a self-produced one right
after last comic and then staying up
records pick that up so that's out there
that's called screaming from the cosmos
okay
then I did not go in angry for the same
company and then this will be three
every then I put another album out in
between
ugly and angry and this one you like
doing the album to the specialist I'd
rather do the specials they're more
effective you know all that shit's just
advertisement for the gigs you know but
yeah the specials are obviously they had
a whole nother element you can make
faces and your jokes can be silent if
necessary when you do it if you're just
doing a record you have to sometimes you
got to rewrite some [ __ ] because you're
doing a visual joke that's not going to
transfer over Spotify I like records I
grew up
listening so I like the the gift of
listening yeah and now it's just so many
[ __ ] specials that you don't have
time to well I always put my special ad
on record like actual vinyl really yeah
I got like ugly and angry is on vinyl
and and lost some alone or both out on
vinyl there's something burning over
there so does it get all your brother
I smell [ __ ] fire from summer huh so
you shoot this August 17 August 17th God
we clear this Friday I went from this
Friday yeah dead in the [ __ ] Colorado
yeah yeah yeah it's gonna be fun I you
know Denver's been a good hang for me
for a lot of years I've done a lot of
good shows there and then I've spent a
lot of time with my friends bands
they're just hanging out and so yeah
it's uh it's definitely gonna be a very
compassionate scene what you were you
were last comics day
2006 huh man it just keeps getting
further and further away but I'm fine
with it
well yeah it's I'd be fine if that's the
last thing people remembered me for what
season did you do two four four yeah
though the first year it came back cuz
three got cancelled like two weeks
before Alonso want I did who were you on
last comic when Josh blue gabriel
iglesias ty barnett finished second hi
boy is he still around he's around he
disappeared for a little bit but he's
back I've seen him quite a bit so but I
think I think he had some family issues
to attend to so ty Barnett Gabriel
yeah that's quite a lineup it's crazy
when you look at like the old San
Francisco lineups yeah like from 90 and
go wow yeah just Patton Oswald and Dana
Gould and just all these [ __ ] heavy
hitters I remember was a guy that took
third in San Francisco one year
Carlton's Richardson from Dallas Texas
or something
yeah my farm in Dallas once he was
lonely and I will have told her my bro
you took third in San Francisco why so
quiet ease I got my life didn't really
nothin really happened it's so weird how
your expectations don't for different
things as a comic and something it
doesn't happen but you know what Chris
the only expectation we have is to be
funny and sometimes we forget that well
I mean there are other things I mean
those people thought just just being
funny would make it but they you also
have to move to somewhere where people
give a [ __ ] and I think that's where
that moves hard to make for some people
might as easy it was for me or other
people and it wasn't easy for me like I
cried the first three hours of my drive
out to Las Angels but like that and I
remember coming home and people be like
how did you move to LA and it's like if
you put your [ __ ] in your car you drive
you stop you take your [ __ ] out you sign
a new lease like it's not hard but for
some people it's hard because you're
leaving everything you've ever known for
a whole new scene and and some people
they keep putting it off because they
think I'll do it next year I'll do it
next year because they're waiting for
the perfect moment to leave but there's
never a perfect perfect moment there's
just the moment and so one moment you
have to take it and you have to put all
your [ __ ] in your car and you have to
get in your car and you have to go you
started driving into the [ __ ] of the
hellhole what you felt like oh yeah I
was so excited I remember I did skidded
it's it's not just because I was excited
scared curious yeah I was 18 different
emotions when I first saw that Hollywood
sign like the 101 south we came from
Seattle like I was scared like
everything came to fruition like I was
scared I was excited I was curious I
wanted to see if things would pan out I
wanted justice I was so like there was a
rainbow of emotions you know
I don't know how it is for other people
when you were excited you had already
done last comic no I got it eight months
later moved out here I got a date but
I'll tell you what I drove in it took me
two days to get into town I got into
town I stayed with Emory Emory the first
two nights I or first two months I lived
here Emory Emory edited the aristocrats
DVD and I think the movie for Paul and
Penn so when I showed up literally
moment one I walked into a Marie's
apartment
Paul provenza's in there they're editing
this movie for DVD and I just I remember
sitting down and being like I'm here now
and I'm already in it well you're more
Marty in the middle of an editing
process so I was like I knew I'd made
also I remember I'd gone to Minnesota
with my uncle the weekend before to his
cabin and we were hanging out and I'm
not kidding you planes and crossed and
left contrails
and it said LA in the sky so I knew I
was set I just knew I had literally seen
it in the sky so I was fine if you could
do something differently well we did
done differently I would have used the
money I made in Last Comic Standing a
little more wisely I had a lot of fun
with it I was told by a friend he was
like he's like you you know what it's
like to live poor have fun living rich
so I spent my money I would come into
town I remember going to Kansas City and
ran in a suite at the nicest hotel in
town and hanging out doing mushrooms
with my friends and this the security
guards coming in and laughing at us
because it reached like we'd but they
didn't care because again I was in a
suite and the nicest hotel in town so
they were just like yeah you're fine
first off the money they come with
handles on number two you earned it yeah
number three you were young you know
you know but I also didn't make enough
money to buy a house yeah you didn't
make no no no wasn't no big deal like
you know the main thing of this whole
thing is loving what you do yeah like
it's so [ __ ] weird that we were lucky
we're very lucky no matter how the story
is the horror [ __ ] of being on the
Greyhound bus or getting bumped a week
of rent these are all what get your skin
thick yeah for today will you go through
tonight everything today that people
think they don't Joey just walks in oh
it's a complete different aggravation
we're talking about how about we're
talking about people like Theo von and
Dean Doreen Kate Quigley that are in
that house they can have wine they can
sell 60 tickets yeah but they can still
feature they can see I'm saying
absolutely that's a weird place to be
after you're a paid your dues yeah
you're always in a weird place you're
never at that place where you want to be
that's what makes this journey [ __ ]
just just undeniable I think would you
do it again yeah I do all of everything
this is everything all starve
yeah have money all of it flat top the
starving times were the best time times
that's what people do not they do not
see them a person goes I cannot I don't
understand how that is fun dude I
remember the days where I do I had to
make $25 because that was enough time to
feed myself twice buy myself a peg
cigarettes and enough to like buy if I
saved enough of it for over three days
they'd buy me another eighth wheat and
that that's how I survived until I made
the next rent check you know I just and
that those were the best times my life
just like literally just hanging out
with my friends because there was
nothing else we can [ __ ] do and
writing jokes and and dreaming about
these time bro well I bought a pack of
joints today do you how many times we
dreamed about that in Kansas City as we
were rolling one and smoke it of [ __ ]
cigarette going man I can't some day
you're gonna be able to buy a pack of
joints you can't do it in Kansas City
but I can do it like just just [ __ ] like
that just [ __ ] amazes me
that where I've come from but you know I
was again I was with my buddy Justin
Leon who I've known literally since I've
started and we we just sat back and the
greatest memories that we talked about
were the memories from those initial
years those three those years from 1 to
4 where you're you're just doing it for
the love of it like you you got day jobs
you're just or you're just struggling or
you're you're at that place where you're
doing maybe a week a month or two weeks
a month like an upper where you can't
hold a regular job but you can barely
make rent yeah that's a tough spot to be
in yeah but it's also it's the best spot
because you come home and you're like
well [ __ ] it I'm probably not gonna make
rent anyway so let's go the boats and
you go the casino and you just hope but
he ain't up losing 50 bucks but it
doesn't [ __ ] matter
because at the end of the you know it
all [ __ ] worked out somehow gently it
really don't really does when you put
your trust in you and your heart into
something you don't think you know [ __ ]
it I'm gonna blow his last 50
something's gonna happen
and something always yo somebody 300 you
only got 75 in the bank might as well
have fun with the 75 we she had a good
time with it do you know do you think
that's I mean do you think you got taken
advantage of at the beginning or moving
on to the beginning but because of your
love for it you need new stuff you're
not supposed to do oh no you're just
terrible you're not taking advantage of
you this is what you have to do yeah
what you have to do not everybody's
gonna give you 50 bucks on your bucks
but they're gonna give you a stage and a
mic in at the power I'm happy just to do
it but maybe into the 10 year mark
cuz I I don't know how would get it they
always take a banjo until you get a
movie yeah you get [ __ ] in the ass
until you get good opportunity you get
[ __ ] on you either gonna use a little
clump and they look again they don't
like wall I'm gonna paint on your custom
over you pay yeah and 10 years later you
going anything anything giving you 20 mm
yeah yeah yeah there was literally the
same amount of people yeah right so it's
it's it's you're always gonna fun and
that's what
okay until the unless you got leverage
you're getting [ __ ] but you wouldn't
do I don't think you would do this spot
if you didn't love it like it was
looking like that right now you're not
looking at it like that at all you're
looking at an opportunity to get funnier
exactly that's all you're thinking about
you gotta cover your ass some way or
another
I remember hosting on the road hosting
make it 150 bucks for the weekend a
weekend and and then you know that you
if you broke even you were happy cuz I
live with my folks and as long as they
come home they'd feed me I didn't
obviously didn't have rent to pay at
that time but yeah I mean it was I
remember being in Wichita Kansas it's
living in the condo I got there a day
early the comics from the last week
we're still there and I just thought it
was the coolest [ __ ] in the world like I
thought it was the great if you put me
in a condom now I'd [ __ ] lose a rage
flip a table but at in that moment I was
like if also if I break even this is
gonna be a great weekend all i got it
was break even buy a 25 bucks to get me
gas home then everything is gravy I'm
gonna tell you comic so - don't listen
them and tell Lee something that you
should get out of your head right now
what I got into comedy when I got into
comedy the day I said to myself it was
like bang before I had been doing comedy
three years and I go this is it like
this is full of dope yeah I knew that it
was gonna be ten years so I saw money
and I knew it was gonna be a stroke and
that's why I started shaving away of
things yeah I forced myself I knew that
I had to make a decision in a year I
knew in Boulder that this thing of
whoring the law just delivering Chinese
food slinging coke yeah just doing
comedy part-time one month one week here
what this is not no work I gotta dive
into this so I started watching less TV
I started forcing myself it's depending
how how do you live broke well you gotta
get a tent you know you got
blankets a sleeping bag and I'll never
forget doing that first dribble run like
two weeks back-to-back and you get a
flat tire and and these are all things
are not included in your budget no dead
not included in your budget all the most
terrible things happen your first
started yeah all those things that your
car the least the whole car blows up
when you could absolutely afford it
you're fine you're fine that [ __ ] never
happens it's the week when you go and
then you run over a deer and the Diaz
leg is I only could happen to you I'll
storm this time Ralphie went some
winning him 500 bucks and on the way up
the elevator the keys fell out of his
finger and they went in the shaft and he
ever stay in the hotel next day and the
guy could only come on Monday morning
and he it was $480 he came back from
Sacramento with $20.00 that for the week
as the keys fell down the elevator shaft
and they couldn't get somebody there
till Monday [ __ ] morning like one of
the chances of that like that's the
comedy game and you just gotta if you
can't cry yeah you can't say them it's
just paying your debt to the universe I
remember playing so one of my first
headlining gigs I did knuckleheads in
Mall of America which is now corona bar
and that's that's the Corolla that's
that's the corona bar when you leave
when you leave them other white bronze
rick francis corona bars old
knuckleheads okay so I knew Tuesday
through Saturday
Minnesota is six and a half hours from
Kansas City they give me $1,200 I've
never seen $1,200 my entire life take a
check I'm literally laughing on my drive
home I'm like what am I gonna do with
all this money I'm gonna be a web site
like this is what websites are just
brand new I'm gonna do all this I'm
gonna do this like I'm really gonna put
it into I'm an hour outside of Des
Moines going through a construction zone
and a deer comes out of nowhere I'll hit
it straight up I can remember this
decapitated the deer I remember that
because I hit the body the head stayed
where it was spun around a couple times
there I'm like are you [ __ ] kidding
me I got a one-hitter I got the little
little dugout little will dugout that
standard set up I pulled off
I lost a headlight everything's pretty
much fine the radiators fine the fans
fine
call my dad I'm just and I'm still
speechless I'm like it's a [ __ ] deer
it's a [ __ ] he's like what are you
talking about I hope I just made as much
money as I've ever made in my entire
life and I just hit a [ __ ] deer and
he's like well because my dad knows me
he's like you need to get rid of
whatever you got and just get here and
it literally cost everything that I
would have put in to a website it was
like literally like five hundred six
hundred dollars was everything over what
I normally made and that you know is
just like that's part of it it's paint
it's like you said it's paying your dues
to universe test you do the moment the
universe test you actually you commit
the universe feels okay let's see how
really committed you are to this and
they test your love for what you're
doing yeah it shows you that you really
want to do this you know I remember
being in the [ __ ] Riviera on weekends
doing the dirty show for sure Ripa
opening up a broken [ __ ] $200 for two
shows and the employer this is a regular
at The Comedy Store it's 98 I thought I
hit the big time 200 hours and a [ __ ]
he gave me through the car left me to
the employee dining room where the food
is already bitten yeah the chicken you
know you know like what tough like he
just insulted me like it was just but I
I couldn't sleep I didn't have refight
that time Rogan did the smokes I didn't
bring reefer with me and I couldn't fall
asleep so I'm walking around I seen
slash he was there for a game in the
convention we saw him on the plane he
was on the southwest of us and
everything from Burbank and I saw him at
the [ __ ] thing that I know
told my ass them I go why the Guns
N'Roses breakup you know and he was very
nice he said he goes are you broke now
and I know yeah cuz he forgot I had
known him from I'm ed I'm ed had a room
and slash a gun in there one night you
know I had to go up and say hello or
something so he knew I was a comic and
well I saw him in Vegas I told him that
he goes if you broke now he goes cherish
these times because this is what
balances you out later he goes Axl
wasn't bounced up and he couldn't handle
the money he made all that once and he
lost it this is what keeps you these
stories when we share them like this
yeah this is the [ __ ] that you dis upon
when your agent says you know I can't
represent you no more cause you said
[ __ ] on that thing you like okay gives a
[ __ ] yeah how we pay a dick and Buffalo
I caught the clap and [ __ ] Pittsburgh
like you just all this bad [ __ ] that
happened to you that at the time you
thought was bad but was really a
blessing that made you a comic hiram all
this [ __ ] makes you a comic I remember
hyah I had four months so I have four
weeks of work in Florida straight ahead
it was like two weeks in Tampa a Naples
gig and then maybe Uncle funny's there
was Uncle funny's Davie Florida
open open for Hedberg as a matter of
fact 17 hours into the trip I've driven
straight men wherever the [ __ ] Georgia I
pull off because I'm tired as soon as I
pull off the car starts shake so the car
at low revs won't hold up so I'm
literally having to kind of keep it like
any time I have to stop I got throw it
into neutral just so the engine will
keep running so I get in the Naples go
to a stop sign and I'm putting up in a
neutral it's an automatic transmission
so I'm going to throw it up into neutral
goes into reverse [ __ ] shreds the
linkage
so now I got to drive it like a manual
like I got to throw it in a low like
you'll hear it in the gear then - and
then drive in an overdrive I do the
whole run I get the engine service
they're like your transmissions [ __ ]
but it works the way it is I have to
drive from Tampa Florida to Kansas City
on this [ __ ] transmission the problem
is when I put the cruise control on
anytime the engine goes to automatically
shift down like if you're climbing up a
hill it would shift into neutral so I
had to be aware of that and then click
and out of Drive click it down myself
and then keep going for 22 hours my
girlfriend cook my girlfriend at the
time was with me she couldn't do it I
mean it's if you don't know it [ __ ]
about cars you're not gonna be able to
hear that [ __ ] and I did it
I remember I was hallucinating from st.
Louis to Kansas City just the entire
time if I saw a truck I would think
there were three cars behind it but
meanwhile I had to make I had to mine
the transmission I drove 22 hours
straight because I had to open for Larry
the Cable Guy for a week straight the
next day and so I got into Kansas City
at 6 a.m. on a Tuesday morning after I'm
driven 22 hours on no sleep just weed
just I don't even drink the hum nodos no
[ __ ] well I don't know coffee at the
time I just kept it was just nothing but
pure will and in the girlfriend passed
out seven hours out she woke up in Saint
Louis she's like oh I'll be up the whole
rest of the time that girl passed out
five minutes in outside of st. Louis it
did not wake up till we hit the curb
into her house I drop her off at 6 a.m.
I get back on my Highway there's a
massive oil spill on i-70 takes me an
hour to do what should have taken 20
minutes and I get home I woke up eight
hours 12 hours later showered did a sold
out Larry the Cable Guy show and like
literally every month every time I made
from a month of work went into fixing
that transmission and you [ __ ] no
regrets no
Gretz [ __ ] them all up des dude [ __ ] em
all what we do that's why we're here
this is it's so crazy how I see people
to think that they just gonna walk up
here and I see it and you know I love
these guys that I've been doing this for
that in this like you have no [ __ ]
idea come back and see me in ten years
and we will talk you have no [ __ ]
idea what you have to go through well
it's like these cats that started in LA
and have been good enough to make it
through the ranks and now they're
getting looks and now they're starting
to do the road and they look at us and
they're like how do you do the road I'm
like that's that's the job that's when
it becomes a job like you're out there
worried people look at me and they go
you do 40 weeks a year how do you do
that I'm like normal people work 50
everybody every blue-collar work either
works gets two weeks of vacation a year
otherwise they clock in 9:00 to 5:00
every week like that's this is what this
is our job we're fortunate enough to be
able to 40 we see it yeah I'm gonna do
probably end up doing 42 this year god
[ __ ] bless you I mean what else am I
gonna do you know yeah and also I'm at a
place where if I'm not doing 40 where
you see I'm not making money like if I'm
living out here you know I'm on the
lowest of low when it comes to the totem
pole at this moment as far as pay scale
so if I'm not out there every weekend I
can't go out on dates be nothing rough
man yeah really Israel but it's also
like it's not rough like other than the
flights no it's pretty easy
no the stand-up you do free it's the
flying to say that movies when you do
movie I'm gonna paid the Act you get
paid to sit around absolutely acting you
do for [ __ ] free but stand-up once
you get there it's phenomenal dude radio
yeah it's phenomenal I wake up let's get
[ __ ] down I love the whole process and
for a while there the business area of
it [ __ ] with you and I fell in love
when they get my head Tori this morning
I got up and I know what I call this the
spots at the start was like there you're
on to something Joey well they call it
night this is what you do like ah
whatever but August 7
August 17th Gotham Theatre Denver listen
you know I love guys you can go to the
my Instagram it's uh I am Chris Porter
and the links in my bio saying with my
Twitter I pinned a tweet and then
because the tickets are free you can
just click on their sign up with it
there's two shows there's one at seven
there's one at 9:30 you request tickets
they're gonna tell you the week of I've
had a lot of people email be like they
haven't told me it's like they tell you
the week but everyone's gonna get in
right okay you know I'm not the link
where can they find that it's out it's
on the link in my bio and my Instagram
at I am Chris Porter my twitter is also
at I am Chris Porter and there's a pin
tweet right at the top it's got the line
Kenan I wish you nothing but luck you
know I I'm one of your biggest fans I
know you one of those guys that [ __ ]
destroys every week and it's just a
matter of time you know I appreciate it
but I love you I'm happy you know I
called you weeks ago yeah you did come
on I miss you you're not gonna you uh
this is what I realized is like you're
not gonna let me fail you'd call me a
wheat you called me and you're like
we're gonna do this I was like great and
then you call me like we're definitely
doing this and then you even call me
yesterday is like it's happening okay
for me to be a good comic to have to be
a good comic to the other comics that's
what makes you a good comic so I'm
starting to learn that without the
comedy business were in the
[ __ ] karma business that's
right so thank you very much I wish you
nothing but luck I will see you in two
months lady they always welcome back in
oh thank you brother promote it wherever
it gets picked up and that's it and I'll
see you [ __ ] tomorrow night in
Kansas [ __ ] City Missouri ready
to [ __ ] go [ __ ] around
Dean down race line in from New York
we're gonna light that [ __ ] place on
fire as usual don't forget if you're
looking for supplements milk shakes
protein shakes [ __ ] shroom tech
sports room tech immune alpha brain
which is one of my favorites you guys
know I live on that [ __ ] go to Holland
right now I'm calm listen they got
kettlebells they've got a bunch of stuff
I can't help you with that but as far as
the supplements are concerned go to
hollaback common press in church and get
10% off your order delivered right to
your [ __ ] door also I love these I
love solo
- dot-com I love the cards I love the
product take a look just go to their
website so legit - calm take a look if
you write the card to order them I think
they're great
I think they great if you travel you
know I mean I play them by myself I try
it I do a couple hip escapes I do a
couple [ __ ] bridges I'd do a couple
sprawls I'm an old man but at least I'm
moving listen have a great weekend I
love you [ __ ] thank you for
listening to Henry Rollins thank you for
listening to my man Chris Porter stay
safe Kansas City
I'll see you [ __ ] tomorrow
night ready to light that [ __ ] town on
fire
have a great weekend see you monday
morning